Now, let's try to understand.
What's statistics is about?
at the high level
without looking at any formulas
So remember I said we will begin with two key terms.
The word population and the word sample the goal
of statistics.
is to
Try to understand.
something about
something we call a population by looking at
a subset
of that population, for example
Let's say you want to know.
How many people live in?
an urban area
Let's say you want to you you're looking
at a city within a certain country and you want to know what is the population of that
country?
now usually
Governments, if they do a good job, they have
something called a census. That means they know everything about all of their people.
Where they live?
How much they make and that kind of thing.
But assuming you don't know exactly.
You mean you don't have you don't have a database of all of the citizens?
In that City and you have to figure out how many people live there.
now
it's not always possible for you
to show up of everyone's door.
Go and say hey, we want to count how many people are in this house and
you start counting them and writing them down.
Oh what you can do.
Is you take?
a part of that City
I can't neighborhood.
And you do your best account everyone in that
neighborhood.
Okay, like you look at.
The house in which they live how many people live in
that house?
And you would take that and you take some of those houses in that
neighborhood and you say okay two story building
four on average four people can
live in that house.
Then you look at the houses in a
closed neighborhood
and how is it in a neighborhood a little farther from that and you
think to yourself? Okay.
If in that neighborhood that we counted.
on average of
You know 200 people were living in that neighborhood.
Then we can use the power of statistics.
to estimate
how many people will be living in those in that
neighborhood in that neighborhood in that neighborhood? Okay. I'm trying
to really simple it make it simple for you.
My point is this you take a sample a subset
of the entire population and use that?
to determine this the entirety of the population
This is the this is the power of Statistics. It allows you to look
at a sample a small piece.
of the puzzle
and then predict
What the entire picture looks like?
Okay, that's a very rudimentary definition of
What statistics is trying to achieve?